[MUSIC PLAYING]
RASHI MITTAL: Hi,
everyone, good afternoon.
I'm really excited to be here.
Before I introduce
myself, I thought
that I would get a sense
of who our audience is.
So one of the first
things-- and I
have to keep on being
close to the Mac,
because I'm using mines.
So it may go on
to sleep, so we'll
try not to make that happen.
So I want to understand
who is here today first.
So let me just ask a
couple of questions.
So how many of you are
actually developers here?
OK, how many of you are in a
security, data privacy, data
protection, legal
compliance function?
OK, all right, so
majority of the people.
So I'm talking to
the right group here.
How many of you are working for
companies that have presence
in more than one country?
OK, great so also
more than half.
And how many of you
are already on GCP?
are on GCP, as well as
have data on the other public
cloud providers like Azure AWS?
And how many of you have still
some of your data on premise?
OK, so it seems like
more than 50% of people
here are in the
security data protection
function, are on cloud,
on GCP, have hybrid type
of a work environment.
OK, great, so that's
really good to know
that helps me tailor the
presentation here a little bit.
So a little bit about me--
I'm Rashi Mittal.
I am working on Data Custodian,
responsible for go to market,
commercialization,
customer engagement,
and talking to
customers, understanding
how we should continue
developing the solution.
So this product has come out
of our partnership with Google.
So it is a layer of
data visibility and data
control for customers
who are sitting on GCP.
So that's what the
product is about.
So before I go a little
bit further and talk
about data and data protection
and the solution itself,
I thought that I would
discuss a little bit about why
SAP is focused on doing this.
So majority of the
people are aware of SAP?
Yes, OK, sometimes
in Silicon Valley,
you'd be surprised I
get questions around,
oh, what is SAP?
So that's good to know.
So SAP's been responsible and
its purpose and its mission
has always been to drive--
to make sure that enterprises
are running better.
And uh oh-- what happened?
Give me a second.
So SAP has been--
I'm going to stay here.
I don't want this to
go to sleep again.
So SAP has been the respons--
its mission has
been to make sure
that enterprises run better.
And we have been,
for years, been
part of making sure that we have
extremely innovative solutions
around business processes.
And so we see Data Custodian
as an extension of that,
as we provide an extra layer
of visibility and control
of your end-to-end data
on Google Cloud Platform.
So as I'm going through
an introduction,
I'm going to go through
sort of the Data Custodian
features, why the solution
has been developed,
the demo, and the
question and answers.
So first let's talk about data.
So we know that we're
living in a world
where there is a lot of data.
Doesn't matter which
organization you're part of,
you're probably
monetizing on your data.
It's often the lifeline
for most customers.
If you're in financial
services, the financial data
is extremely important.
If you are in retail, I'm
assuming a lot of customers
here are from the
retail industry.
So they are using data
for their operations,
for making sure that they
are selling and putting
the right products out there.
If you are in health care,
a very regulated industry,
but the data volume keeps
increasing with genomics,
with clinical studies,
a lot of your records,
which used to be on paper, now
are electronic health records.
So the volume of data just
keeps on increasing, right?
And that's a fact.
So the question becomes what
should I do about this data,
and how do I protect it?
So you are here at Google Next,
and a majority of the people
here are already on cloud.
So I don't necessarily
need to speak too much
about the benefits
of public cloud,
but I will say that the
reason why a lot of you
have placed your
data on public cloud
is because of the
various benefits, which
include scalability, elasticity,
pricing, reduced implementation
time.
Even so, if you
look at the studies,
only a small
percentage of companies
have a public-only
cloud architecture.
And what I mean by that is
you may have some of your data
on public cloud,
but many companies
are hesitant to put all of their
data, especially sensitive data
or data maybe--
some of their data, maybe
European data, et cetera--
on public cloud for
various reasons.
So can anybody say
why that may be true
that the cloud adoption is still
not where we would want to see,
where I'm sure Google
would want to see?
Loss of control--
any other answers?
OK, perception-- OK, great, yes.
So I think those are
all very good answers.
So we did an [INAUDIBLE]
survey recently.
And in that [INAUDIBLE] survey--
not just because this
is a security session,
but security did come as
sort of number to third
after implementation issues
and migration cost issues
as the reason why cloud adoption
is not where it should be
or where Google would want, for
example, cloud adoption to be.
But the security-- so we went
a little deeper into that, OK,
what does security mean?
And security could mean some of
the identity access management
issues, but it is a lot of
things around perception.
It is an emotional thing
for a lot of customers,
who are used to having
their data on premise
for a very long time.
And now, putting
it on public cloud,
they have lost the
control-- they've
given control to a third party.
And there is a
lack of visibility,
there is a lack of
complete transparency
as to where the data is.
And that is a continued
concern, which
is a concern we're trying to--
we're hoping to solve
with SAP Data Custodian.
One of the other concerns
that I've heard--
so SAP is a European company.
So I've traveled
to Europe, and I've
talked to some of our customers
there, some of our salespeople
there.
And I think one of the
concerns that comes up,
and this concern is very
relevant with the Facebook
Cambridge Analytica case
that recently happened.
Well, if we give
access to our data,
is it being accessed in an
unauthorized, unintended way?
That's a huge concern for
many customers as well.
And that access,
so it's surprising
when you look at
a lot of breaches,
people think, oh,
all these breaches
must be happening
because of hackers.
In fact, interestingly,
it's your own employees
often because of
either negligence
or because they have
gone rogue, for example,
that leads to a lot of
issues around some type
of a breach, et cetera.
So your own cloud
provider access as well as
access by your own
employees is something
that is a huge concern.
Especially when you put the
data on a public cloud platform,
the concern becomes, well, will
I have visibility and control
and can I have some level
of full control over that.
The third, I think,
point-- so we
talked about transparency
and control, talked
about cloud provider access.
I think the third
issue that also
becomes a concern for some
customers or a challenge,
if you will, for many customers
are the data protection
regulations that are varying.
So how many of you have heard
and have worked with GDPR?
OK, so a majority of the room.
So it just went into effect.
There's GDPR.
There are also various--
almost 60 countries, I was
reading something last night.
There are almost 60
countries that have varying
data protection regulations.
And after GDPR
going into effect,
I'm sure there will be other
countries that are not only
coming up with new regulations.
So cloud is globally connected.
When you place your data in
a global connected cloud,
I think, for some customers
the concern becomes,
which law will apply?
So the concern is
not just cannot--
the concern could be data
localization and data residency
laws that exist all
throughout the world.
But the other concern
is which law applies
if my data does move around.
And that's where there are
some needs for having something
around geolocation.
So given the various challenges
around privacy, around
transparency, around
control, I think
the question becomes, well,
how can companies benefit
from public cloud
and still retain
control of their business data.
So this is where we thought
that trust but verify
is an extremely
important concept.
So we're moving
towards innovation,
we're here in the Bay Area.
Everybody wants to
innovate quickly.
There's a lot of data.
The data volume is growing.
So the choice or
the option is not
to keep all your data
stored on premise.
Cloud has a lot of benefits
as we talked about it,
and you want to be able
to use public cloud.
But how do you stay
in public cloud,
but still be able to have some
level of control and visibility
of your data?
Well, you can have a third
party that can help you
with verification around that.
And our [INAUDIBLE]
survey actually
helped in that response as well,
that a verification mechanism
with a third party
that it already
has a relationship
with the enterprises
makes a lot of sense.
So which is where SAP
Data Custodian comes in.
SAP data custodian, there's a
little dashboard over there.
It is a SaaS application
that we have developed.
And the first phase
of this solution
is generally available.
So I'll go a little bit deeper
into what this solution is.
So before I go into that, we
have defined data custodians
to be responsible for the
implementation of business
rules that relate to the access
and protection of business
data.
So as I mentioned, there are
two key phases of our solution.
There is data
transparency, which
is generally available
which helps with monitoring
and reporting of data access,
storage, and movement,
and processing of your
data in the public cloud.
So you will have more visibility
into how your data is accessed,
how it's stored, where
it's being moved,
and where it's being
processed in the public cloud.
And the data control
is our second part
of the solution,
which is going to be
available throughout
the rest of the year.
We're working on that, so
we have a very robust policy
engine that we have developed
out of Data Custodian.
So an example for that would
be that you are a company,
and you have some sensitive
data sitting in Germany,
maybe your HR data in Germany.
And you may want to keep
some of that data only
within Germany on public cloud.
You can develop a policy
through our portal,
and we are able to, in
the data control piece,
actually enforce those policies.
In the first section,
we're giving you
a lot of robust visibility,
monitoring, and reporting.
And then the second
section, we're
able to help you with the
enforcement of those policies,
and I will go to a demo so this
will all become more clear.
So as I mentioned,
the transparency
is going to help you answer
the following key questions--
where is my data stored,
how has the data been moved
and processed, and who
is accessing my data
and from which location?
So I think, as some
people here mentioned,
that they are concerned about
what is happening to that data
once it is in public cloud.
That's what this part of
the product helps with.
And I think I also heard
control over there, so this
is where the second part of--
the functionalities, which
are going to come soon,
are going to help with.
So it's helping with
your governance.
It's helping with
your compliance.
And essentially, this is
where SAP truly becomes,
quote unquote, "Data
Custodian," where
we are able to help enforce the
geolocation controls for data
access, storage,
processing, and movement.
So I think the question
I have received often
is, well, why SAP?
And I started out
with saying SAP helps
with enterprises run better.
We have been masters and
have a lot of expertise
around business processes.
But further along, we have a
lot of expertise in governance,
risk, and compliance.
We have a lot of knowledge
about public cloud platforms.
And even so, we are actually
independent of public cloud
platforms, and I
think that's where
that the concept of
trust, but verify
becomes really important.
So this is why it makes
sense for SAP to come in,
and you may already have an
existing relationship with SAP.
You may be using our
various applications,
our various business
processes, and this
will be yet something
else that we can help you
with while are in public cloud.
So this is where I'm going
to do a little demo for you.
OK, great.
So this is our dashboard.
So let's say that
you have [INAUDIBLE]..
There you go.
So let's say that you're already
starting to use Data Custodian,
and you come in Monday morning.
Maybe your cloud analyst
wants to make sure
that they have full visibility
of your data on public cloud.
So they will sign
into this home page.
They'll sign into
the cockpit view,
and they're going
to see a few things.
Before they see that
though, I wanted
to go into the My Cloud tab,
which is a very important tab.
So let's say before
you have-- so I've
talked about that we
have a very robust policy
engine with Data Custodian.
So before you
develop the policies,
you can come to
this page and are
able to see where all your
data is distributed globally
on Google Cloud Platform.
So this is sort of your
data placement view,
and you can see that your data
is spread all over the world.
Some of it is in India, some
is Europe, some in the US.
So just having a visibility
of how your data is spread out
is exactly helping
with that visibility
that we were talking about.
Similarly, you can see where
the data is being accessed from.
So some of your data may
be sitting in Europe,
but it's being accessed,
whether by our employee,
maybe a Google support
engineer, or from United States.
You can also see--
sorry, it's a little slow.
Well, technically, it should
be showing data movement.
Let's just pretend
that it did, and we'll
go back to the home page.
And I'll show you data
movement in another view here.
So, again, going back
to the home page,
so we have this
concept of unions
that we have coined
with Data Custodian.
The concept of union is a
geolocation defined area
where your data can be placed,
stored, moved, or processed.
So here you can see that we have
US-China union, which probably
is slightly less
realistic, but you
can have a Canada-Brazil union.
So you may want your data to be
staying and access and process
and move between
Canada and Brazil.
And you can have
a European union,
and I will go into
the policy management,
so you'll be able to see how we
are developing the policies as
well.
So you can have
the European union,
and I'll just click on that.
And there you can see that
you have on the corner
here on the left
hand side, you can
see how the compliance has
been for the European union
in the last few days.
You can see what
alerts have come up.
So you have five level of alert.
So a level one alert is
not as scary probably
as a level five alert.
So level five alert may
be an example of you
have very strict
German regulations.
You want some of your HR
data to stay within Germany,
but for some reason, it has
moved outside of Germany.
And that might be a risk level
that you have assigned five,
and that would show
up as an alert.
So we're seeing a
risk level of four.
We're seeing how
the risk overview
has been for the European
union in the last seven days.
In the side here,
you have a lot of
other interesting information
about the European union,
and how much data is stored
there, and how much of it is--
So there's also a
tagging functionality
as part of our solution.
So you can tag the data to
be highly sensitive or less
sensitive.
And so here we distribute-- so
most of the data here it seems
is sensitive.
And you can see total storage
size as well as resources.
So we have Data Custodian
at the infrastructure level.
So what we are actually
showing visibility of
is all your infrastructure
level data--
so virtual machines,
your disks, your buckets.
So you can see what
the resources look
like for this particular union.
So I'm going to go
to the union itself
and see if we have
any alerts there.
Actually, before I do
that, let me show you
how to make a policy.
So because the policy engine
is a very important part
of the solution.
So I'm going to go and
see European union.
So I will show you the--
so here to define a policy--
and this is something
that you can do--
is you're going to have
a name of the policy.
You can have an action
of allow or deny.
You will have an operation.
So the four operations right
now that we're looking into
are access, placement,
movement, and processing.
You will have resource classes.
So this is a very interesting
part of our policy engine.
So either you can
say all my resources
in Google Cloud Platform, or
you can get more granular.
So you can either choose
it by resource classes,
so you can say all my virtual
machines or all my buckets.
Or you can also be
even more granular
and, say, choose
a specific bucket,
so that the bucket in Germany
with that German HR data
might be something that
you can pick and have
a specific policy for that.
So you choose how
granular you want to be.
Now, you also have
to choose a location.
So is your data is
sitting in European union,
that's your resource location.
And now, this is actually
an access policy.
So you are saying,
I actually don't
want some of my data to be
accessed from the United
States.
So I don't want all of my
data sitting in European union
to be accessed from
the United States.
So that's something
that you can choose,
and you can choose
other countries as well.
And you can choose--
so if it's access,
there two accesses
that we are monitoring.
So it's your own customer
access, your own employee
access, as well
as Google access.
So you can choose
either all, that you
don't want any of your access
from a Google support engineer,
or your own employee access to
happen from the United States.
Because you're concerned
about US regulation,
you're concerned that
under Patriot Act,
maybe the government is
going to somehow want
some of that data,
which is sitting--
and so that's why you
want to really keep
some of your data
defined and controlled
and not being accessed
outside of Europe.
And that could be a good
reason why you want to do that,
or you could have some other
technology or other reasons.
And then you have
to define a risk
level, which can be lowest,
low, medium, high, or highest.
And then that's a summary of
a policy that you would have.
So going back to the
home page, I'm not sure
if there are any questions.
I'm going to go back
to the European union
and show you what happens
when an alert comes up.
I may have to change it
to the last three months.
Oh, maybe, that's what it is.
So, I mean, we've generated some
data for this particular demo,
so it's showing a lot of alerts
and a lot of these red alerts.
So I'm going to click on
one of these red alerts
to see what's going on.
So as I click on it,
we see that there
has been an access violation.
So I just went
through the policy
that we just developed, which
was the policy that you don't
want your European union data to
be accessed by somebody sitting
in the United States.
Except in this case, there
was an actual violation
that happened.
And so in this particular
case from our transparency
where our product
is today, you can do
a couple of different things.
You can get more
information about that
and see why that
may have happened.
So in this case,
it may be that one
of your employees from
the European union
is actually traveling
to the United States,
and you feel comfortable with
them accessing this data.
If that's the case,
then you can verify it
by saying, OK, employee
moving and then submit that
and then that will make
the policy go away.
So let's just do.
And then as soon as you
have resolved the policy,
and it goes from red to green.
Another option would be
that you can actually
change the policy itself.
So maybe there have
been some changes
in where did you want your
data to be accessed from.
Maybe you're not comfortable
with that all being accessed
from US, because you've opened
up a new center in the US
and you know a lot
of your US employees
are going to be accessing it.
So you could also go ahead and
completely change the policy
and no longer have this policy.
So those are the various things
you can do with the alerts.
And just wanted to show
you one other thing
quickly before I
open it up for Q&A.
So you also have the
option to actually run
reports which is something
that your data privacy
officer or your legal compliance
department may want to use.
And depending on
the dates, you will
have a lot more information
around what the alert trends
have been, the risk
level of these alerts,
resolve versus
unresolved alerts,
the data type, et cetera.
And again, in this
case, because we've
generated some
data for this demo,
you can see that there a
lot of unresolved alerts.
Hopefully, that's
not going to happen.
Hopefully, you're
not actually having
a lot of these violations.
You're having fewer
violations and you
are able to investigate
and resolve them
on a day-to-day basis.
So that was a quick demo.
We also have a lot of
our team here, technical,
and our developers and
our product owners.
So happy to answer
any questions.
So I can answer
them, and we also
have other people
who can help answer.
And we also have people
from Google here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]